[Music]
a baseball glove is basically an
addition to your hand that allows you to
trap the balls between the thumb and the
index finger in such a fashion that you
can make a great catch and throw it back
so the time I started playing baseball
I've been in love with something very
basic about it it's not about fads or
this or that about a rich heritage that
goes back over a hundred years
[Music]
I'm Rob story I'm the executive vice
president
I cut the ball gloves we make world
class ball gloves here in Nocona Texas
to build a fluff you're going to have to
have the right leather we use a number
of different letters such as kangaroo
cowhide buffalo even some caiman when
that comes into us we begin the grading
process we're looking for any blemishes
scars defects with a classic walnut Club
we're going to be using the leather that
we call walnut crunch it's very durable
but very easy to break in a lot of
players lock that because I can go out
to play catch immediately we introduced
the cutting knives or what we call
clickers basically big cookie cutters
we've got to take that leather and cut
it into about 25 different pieces we've
have somewhere about 2,000 cutting dies
while the leather still flap do what we
call hot stamping it will take other
pieces to the embroidery station where
we have six and seen ahead
that can help out four to five hundred
dollars today putting all that
information somewhere on the weather so
that the customers educated
[Music]
once that's done then it's time to
transition over to the stitching
department two or three of the pieces go
a different direction where they're made
into the web or the pocket of the log
another station will start the interior
lining this is the part that the hand
touches not only the palm lining that
the back fingers as well as three Center
pads inside start to welt those parts
together where we're adding a third
piece of material in between the scenes
setting a spine to the backs of the
fingers of the glove really at that
point again to see the glove come
together
the fingers are finally married to the
front and it becomes a ship once you've
closed a glog it's inside out literally
push the leather down and push the
inside back to the outside then it's
time to start shaping the glove and we
do that through a series of forms that
look like giant hands they're heated to
about 250 degrees Fahrenheit pulled
around and shaped with a mallet so that
all the welting and all the seams are
just perfectly aligned
[Music]
living in a small town like that kind of
Texas is a big part of who I am I think
the kind of bungalows
wouldn't necessarily work somewhere else
it's about the local people in the pride
the town itself is very much a part of
the final product I'm a fourth
generation family member in the company
and in the 1960s most baseball glove
manufacturers decided to take their
manufacturing offshore
my grandfather mob story didn't want to
do that he wanted to give employment to
the locals he made a decision at that
point that was very crucial to the long
term history of our company and that was
that we were going to be american-made
something that's been a part of
Americana for decades and decades but
they can't find anywhere else now in the
United States there are up to 40
different labor operations that go into
making a glove and so it's not just
sticking a piece of leather in a machine
more and more people are starting to
realize just because you can make it
cheap way somewhere else that doesn't
make it good you've got to put the very
best craftsmanship in
we think our history of 80 plus years of
doing that we've learned how to do it
leather it's one of the most interesting
materials known to man
the field is firmly wrapped around your
hand the subtle pop doesn't ball hits it
these characteristics four things that
make crafting and with this medium one
of the most enjoyable parts of my job
[Music]
after the forming marry the outside
shell with the inside line we're going
to be gluing some parts together so in
the inside liner take long strips of
tensile strength laces and start filling
120 holes in the glove cosmoline holds
the palm to the inside of the liner into
very heavy form of petroleum jelly it
looks a lot like peanut butter it's a
great adhesive we can open up into love
10 years later and that stuff still
sticky inside first the top fingers then
the bottom perimeter of the glove and
finally the web which usually kind of
gives the glove its character into one
finalized piece
[Music]
we will physically beat the palm of the
glove and that softens the glove shapes
and leather takes out all the wrinkles
and makes it just right
we take hot petroleum jelly and lanolin
and we spray that onto the gloves so
that we have a very uniform layer of oil
that starts to moisturize the leather
just like skin if left to its own design
will start to dry out and crack and
flaky if we bag we tag the glove seal it
up and get it ready to go out to the
market
even though it's evolved through the
years it's still very very personal to
each player that uses a glove I think to
our customers McCullough bought gloves
represent a product that is rich in
heritage at the top level of the game
and hopefully last for decades to come
[Music]
you
[Music]
you